you've been coming on the show for many
many yes or talk about your
relationships your ups your downs lot of
downs yeah be honest you've had your
share of troubles
what's going on with relationships now
right now I'm dating somebody it seems
to be going well I just got done dating
somebody else that was a little tricky
yeah it was uh why is that funny
yeah we don't think I got game I got
game look at me these are real glasses
yeah yeah he doesn't stand a chance with
women he's wearing the glass exactly
keep him off them yeah all right so here
we go what are we talking about oh the
last one long-distance situation
long-distance yeah thanks off they are
but you have Skype now Skype helps all
right you yes guy in a relationship
because you can talk in real-time with
the person on the computer you can save
romantic things like you know come
closer so your head is actual size and
also you can have man loves me yeah so
uh you can have sex on skype I don't
know if you know that yes you can yeah
but I'm those who know notes and I'm
gonna give you one pointer with the
Skype sex just stay focused and don't
look at the little box in the corner
that's that's the trip
the box the boxes one though here's what
happens you're like okay this is going
well and you're like who's a sad
masturbating guy and then you have that
Smee stay on earth
beep look in the hearth and why do you
keep that box open for positioning you
want to make sure you got it all in
there yeah yeah all right I didn't think
people could do that I honestly didn't
think you could have sex once you have
sex anywhere any for me what you got
right now and no one would know I would
probably know their room though that's
Andy he's got a tick
you